how are you from another mejía with his
briefing today is thursday
july 15 the
clark county fire department responded to a
gas leak this morning near poulter highway
emails it is recommended that drivers
avoid the area what
firefighters  they finish the work and
conclude with the investigation we
will keep you informed with all the
details on our page
diagonal dotcom edition in Spanish
and get ready because today the
winners of the second round of
the pax never gates incentive program are announced for
all those people fully vaccinated against
the hobbit  or those who have
obtained at least one dose
automatically participate in this raffle,
all coverage will begin at
6 p.m. you can follow it on our
website or social networks
and if you still do not know where to get your
coronavirus vaccine  there are several
clinics available around the valley
until saturday you will be able to get it
v  Visiting green bay robinson high school
yesterday ivan had between
10am and 4pm plus
copper shots and will also
be offering other immunizations
required by the school district
for back to school today and tomorrow there
are clinics as well  available at the
general and webber schools and now we go to
the weather conditions we will continue with
some breezes coming from the southwest
of the valley for the afternoon however it
will not avoid the extreme heat since we will
reach 108 degrees for today
by Sunday we will have chances
of drizzle  Once again, these will last
until the middle of next
week. Have a nice diary. I'm Héctor
Mejía and this was your briefing about
them, Spanish is spoken
[Music]